the readout of the college missing of
today 19th of February 2020
I will give the floor to the executive
vice president fest hire to do the
college readout she is accompanied by
the commissioner face stager because
together they will talk to you about an
important item which was on the agendas
of the college today exactly vice
president the floor is yours oh thank
you very much
good afternoon very happy to be here
with my colleague Julie we have you know
the digital package today but first a
few words on the college as such the
president and commissioner Hahn they
gave us an overview of the preparations
of tomorrow's special summits on the
multi-annual financial framework then
Michelle Bonnie our chief negotiator he
updated us on the state of play on the
negotiations on the future EU UK
partnership and last but not least the
College discussed a European citizens
initiative which is entitled a start
unconditional basic income in its
current form the initiative fails
outside the scope of the Commission
competence and you know that is the only
way we can adopt it or promote it and
that is why the college decided to
contact the organizers and inform them
of this analysis and then maybe the
organizers will come back they will have
two months to do so to see if they will
amend the initiative so that it can move
on only then we will take the final
decision as to whether to endorse
endorse the the start of the process or
not but most of the time today we spent
discussing our digital policy package
and this is a a package that is meant to
define how we shape europe's digital
future in a way that serves
or the digital package is composed of
three components the first is an
overarching strategy communication to
set out our vision for a digital society
that works for all seconds a white paper
on artificial intelligence that proposed
a framework both to embrace the
opportunities that artificial
intelligence gives us but also to tackle
the risks triggered by this technology
the point obviously is to create trust
rather than fear finally and very
importantly our data strategy aims to
make sure that both businesses and
public entities have access to more data
and to good quality data so they can
innovate provide better public services
in the way that of course fully
preserves our rights and values I will
say a few words about the artificial
intelligence white paper really will
take you through the data strategy just
to say a few words first about our
communication this shape in europe's
digital future this has a clear purpose
we want to make sure that every citizen
every employee every business well they
stand a fair chance of reaping the
benefits of digitization whether that
means to drive more safely in a
connected car reducing the use of
pesticides in agriculture or saving
lives with AI scans that allows doctors
to detect a disease give a diagnosis and
start treatment much faster than ever
before
and it is a bit like assembling a puzzle
so the data strategy and the white paper
on AI today are only two pieces of that
puzzle and obviously only when we have
put together the rest of the puzzle the
fourth picture will be seen the three
objectives
or the pictures that will come when we
have a sample to puzzle should
illustrate three objectives first that
technology should work for people and
not the other way around it is first and
foremost about purpose the development
the deployment the uptake of Technology
must work in the same direction to make
a real positive difference in our daily
lives and that is difficult to achieve
but still more easily achieved if Europe
both shapes and masters such technology
itself second that we want a fair and
competitive economy a full single market
where companies of all sizes can compete
on equal terms well the road from garage
to scale-up is as short as possible but
it also means an economy where the
market power helped by a few incumbents
cannot be used to block competition
it also means an economy where consumers
can be taken forgiven that their rights
are being respected and where profits
are being taxed where they are made
thirdly we want to continue to live in a
open democratic and sustainable society
and this means a society where citizens
can control the data that they provide
where digital platforms are accountable
for the contents that they feature
obviously this is not just sort of a
nice to have this is a fundamental thing
because it is the fundamental thing that
while we used new digital tools use AI
as a tool that we built a society based
on our fundamental values and
fundamental rights vice-president
euroval will presents a democracy action
plan later in this mandate in order to
address exactly these points also about
democracy last but not least
a sustainable society where digits not
ignored the technologies actively enable
the green transition as we see it the
green transition will not happen without
digital technologies without satellite
data analyzing our crop fields telling
us where resources are being used how
waste can be prevented we cannot do it
without GPS data that allow us to cut
the shortest possible routes minimize
driving and spending time on the roads
and of course also the invisible thing
like sensors in our water pipes to give
us an alert when there is a risk our
water being wasted more than ever green
transition and digital transition goes
hand in hand all of this of course not
done in splendid European isolation
Europe has been an inspiration to many
jurisdictions around the globe and we
will remain the most open region in the
world when it comes to trade and
investment but of course whoever does
business in Europe needs to respect our
rules and values while doing business
here so on the artificial white paper in
itself or the artificial intelligence
white paper because the white paper is
indeed not artificial the major point
here can seem very far away from digital
because the idea is to build trust
without trusts we cannot make all the
positive things happen I think you will
see it the same way that artificial
intelligence is not good or bad in
itself it all depends on why and how it
is being used artificial intelligence
which reproduce human language can make
a chatbot much better and give us a
better consumer experience but it can
also be used to create fake news and
because of that job jeopardize
fundamentals in our democracy
and this is why the paper has a double
approach on the one hand site I create
an ecosystem of excellence here you find
key enablers to make the most of
technology and an ecosystem of trusts
which mitigates the risk that artificial
intelligence may pose to fundamental
values discrimination causing harm
ecosystem of excellence is built on five
priorities first and that of course is
very very on the agenda this week
funding we need public funding that the
EU funding national funding but private
funding as well to fund research and
development second for research and
development efforts to be more effective
well we need to make sure that our
organization of that is strong that we
have a lighthouse for talent to be
attracted for talent to see that this is
a place to go and also to make sure that
we have a network of centers of
excellence all over Europe
thirdly talents is a thing but skills as
important we need a lot of people to be
able to work with artificial
intelligence without that deployment
especially in small and medium sized
businesses will be way too difficult and
that would be the last thing in creating
an ecosystem of excellence that small
and medium-sized businesses they are
invited in the digital innovation hops
could be an an absolute starting point
for more businesses getting on board the
thing is that none of the positive
things will be achieved if we distrust
the technology if we as consumers as
parents as individuals feel unsafe feel
that digital technologies they're not
helping our us in our daily lives
they are undermining what we stand for
and this is why we have this
accompanying idea of an ecosystem of
trust when you look at the technology as
such well then you will see that it
comes all the way from nice-to-have to
life or death so it is important to try
to understand what is the kind of risks
that we want to deal with to start
several specific situations would
immediately raise a red flag that could
be when artificial intelligence tackles
fundamental values it could be life or
death situation any situation that could
cause material or immaterial harm or
expose us through discrimination and in
order then to scope what could be future
legislation well we would first look at
the sector where artificial intelligence
is being used that could be recruitments
that could be law enforcement's could be
health care and energy in this sector
you'll find a lot of the characteristics
I just mentioned the second criteria
would be then the specific use of
artificial intelligence within that
sector if you look at the health care
system well it may be so that an
appointment system is absolutely poses
no risk to fundamental values why an AI
assisted surgery may indeed be something
that you would want to look at in case a
a AI product or service is then
identified to pose risk well then we
would want to have an enforcement
mechanism that should be consists of a
thorough conformity assessment to test
that the product is safe before it is
put into use and this conformity
assessment that will test a number of
obligations we have based our suggestion
on those made on the high level expert
group on ethics to create trustworthy AI
there are four of them
first that AI systems should be trained
using data that respects European values
and rules and the record of such data
should be kept seconds AI system should
provide clear information to users about
its purpose its capabilities but also
its limits so that it's clear to use
this also when they interact with an
artificial rather than a human
intelligence third an AI system needs to
be technically robust and accurate in
order to be trustworthy and fourth AI
systems should always ensure an
appropriate level of human involvement
and oversight if an AI products or
service is not identified as high risk
well it would still have obligation
because we still have data protection
and privacy non-discrimination and
product and safety liability rules
within the Union and since this is for
everything this is also for toys and for
televisions and for any other product
will we will assess if this legislation
is sufficient or if more is needed to do
on the legal front specifically here the
thing is that when you talk about
enforcement you would want to make sure
that national authorities are not left
on their own to address individual cases
so in order to make sure that we also
have a single market for artificial
intelligence that has passed the
conformity assessment we will need a
European governance structure which
consists of a framework for cooperation
of national authorities necessary to
avoid fragmentation of responsibilities
finally it is important to check if it
is possible to enforce your rights when
it comes to liabilities because part of
the nature of artificial intelligence is
that it is opaque so even though you
have your rights and you know that if
something happens with the product that
you
know who is liable we need to check that
you can actually actually have these
rights in real life depending on how the
technology is used last but not least
there has been a discussion about
artificial recognition of nonsense
facial recognition in the last couple of
weeks in some instances facial
recognition will be harmless I think by
now most people know it you unlock your
phone or you have it in an automatic
border control facial recognition may
also be used to remote identification in
public spaces here it's not necessarily
just your face it can be the way you
walk your gates a lot of different
things concerning your body can be used
to identify you it's a very different
cup of tea than just opening your phone
with this white paper the Commission is
launching a debates of the specific
circumstance if any which might justify
the use of such technologies in public
space finally you know we are what we
eat
same goes with artificial intelligence
and this is why this first digital
package would not at all be complete
without a dedicated data strategy and
clearly you will you will take us
through that
merci beaucoup my great pleasure
translator intelligence artificial from
GBC a challenge when Oporto ex-premier
por la première fois Pomona College in
trabecular Murphy Eric McGrath is Julie
Asti magnetic Nostrand inoculate a screw
chavacano penetrant pooja de la Jara mm
Oh correct if ecology are challenged
defesa or sore loser almond croissant a
pooja dream
hey did you tell her who collage Bosco
see the première fois que continúa
renewed present this ha TV career heart
a la fois Chantilly gossiped emissary
Israeli dhuni Oakmont challenge she's
resilient hominid do them challenge
comes over Valley solute Valley City
Utah to a Castillo so in order to be
even faster we speak in English so the
first thing that and of course my god
said everything about but III don't want
to come back on this it's absolutely
critical that all our citizens will feel
confortable and of course that we have
to put your set the right set of
regulation to make them confortable and
to preserve all our values but on the
other hand it's true that you cannot
speak about AI if you don't speak about
data because I'm a great side you are
what you eat
same thing for a application AI is of
course an application you have an
Android but at the very beginning you
have a huge amount of data that you have
to run and run and run on machine
learning process that's why if even you
want to to see who you are
yeah but you eat but you are what you
are you not open your sir you're not
open to see but what is insider so same
thing for I'll guide you don't open it
you just had to make sure what kind of
data use do you use where they come from
if they are consistent with our
regulation GDP of instance and so on so
the good news if I may say so is that in
this area we recognize that we missed
the first wave of the first battle which
was the battle of personal data we
missed it is true and we know exactly
why we know that it started in the US
with huge platforms by the way sorry to
say under and dog missile similarly say
it was not rocket science in terms of
technology to start these platforms
but it's true that some big pad from 10
years ago 2002 available to you to to
have a huge success because it was
already a current internal data market
but wisdom see in China and it true that
us oh my god and we know that we were a
bit too fermented but this is also the
way we are and we have seen huge
platform appearing everywhere not a web
in the US and including of course in in
Europe and we know exactly what happened
we know that they were using personal
data our personal data by the way you
have reacted pretty well with gdpr and
it was our duty to do it and i'm
congratulation for the previous private
commission to update and and and that's
way it is but now i said the good news
that room this time what happened and we
know also that what we have in follow us
is is the fact that we are entering into
an era where the biggest amount of data
created will come from b2b and
industrial sectors and that's huge just
to give you another magnitude today the
planets in the beginning of humanity and
now represent 40 zettabyte already sells
us to some of you forty thousand vision
or middle of data that our heritage our
legacy interval data today within the
next 18 months we will just double the
number of that are created since the
beginning of humanity
till now 18 months will have on the
planet 80,000 billion of billion of data
and most of this data as Mehcad
mentioned will come mostly from our
activities not us personally not our way
to exchange but our ability to behave in
an more complex environment thanks to
the
5g networks and of course entering into
the IOT world and by the way this number
will be multiplied by 2 every 18 months
and of course it means that here we have
to be very careful
understand houses that are created we
will created and what can we do with it
including of course to use them to build
new algorithm artificial intelligence
applications so that's exactly where we
stand now and this is why I already said
already Munich with you migrate during
the weekend and I say so in the battle
for industrial data starts now and
Europe will be so many battlefield why
because we have in Europe the more
current the strongest and the largest
industrial base and most of this data at
the beginning will come from our
industries and and as described by the
way everyone is extremely interested to
see what we will do so my message here
and our message collectively that we
made an intense work and thank you also
for DG's here energy connect but but not
only and and yes we announce you that we
have everything in Europe to win this
battle because no one has the expertise
of this battle and the foundation
industry base than the noise and that's
why we say maybe that the winner of
Optimo will not be the winner of two
more of the we love tomas we will not be
the winner of today or yesterday and
this is where we stand so what do we
need here and what we will present again
quickly in in this document that you
will you will have time to read three
things first regulatory framework
including data art to unlock unused data
in other words a single market for
industrial public b2b data and by the
way one of our colleagues this morning
where the long station my guys said wow
it is probably as important as when we
created a single market yes it's true
when you see the importance of what is
at stake
and of course in this first dimension
let's say we will Iraq and present some
rules on that axis sharing that
extremely important use reuse
anonymization and so on the second
pillar is is based on infrastructure and
platforms in order to run this data you
need to have specific platform and you
remember the session we had for 5g we
already explained that it will be mainly
diversifies on the pervasive way
remember the 2880 2020 80 most of this
data will be created locally and
processed locally
thanks to five z5g critical network
deployment but also locally to have edge
devices by the way by 2030 we expect on
the planet to add 500 billion connected
devices 500 billion out of all these
devices we exchange information
extremely extremely quickly and here of
course we need 2,000 specific what is
the way you want mini cloud or edge
devices to store this data and to
interact locally with the applications
applications and better on top of this
and believe me the requirement for these
platforms and autotrol the requirement
that you see on a personal b2c platform
because of course when you exchange the
information and your favorite social
network okay that's fine
but now when as Margaret said it is just
to make sure that in an Hospital the
robot is exactly right or that a
connected car will take the right
decision immediately immediately that's
another story and then we need of course
raw business you need of course security
and cyber security everywhere you need
to have of course latencies need to
react in terms of millisecond
number Ten's not tens of second as a
totally different infrastructure and we
have the tools here we have the
companies in Europe being able to do
this and by the way nobody in the world
today is doing it just because the
market was not ready but market is here
in Europe so that's why we will lunch
also European industrial flooded but
from alliance to to have all companies
interesting here to be able to answer
and to build these platforms and we want
you to to mobilize up to two billion
euros in order to to create and to help
this audience of course we will also use
we have a very interesting
infrastructure today in HPC
high-performance computing on HP it's
called UHPC we may use it also to have a
specific platform here for public data
into academic quad and research the
subpoena is sector of specific actions
to build European specific European data
spaces for instance in industrial
manufacturing grain deal mobility has
cities and so on and and he of course
putting in place the right governance
rules in between so that's basically
what you will find is this document of
course we will answer with my guide on
to your questions
one final word on one platform is to if
I may the wall in our society and
economy is of course to to protect our
people and our markets and Michael said
it very well but I am very clear it's
not us that need to adapt to today's
platform it is the platforms that need
to adapt to Europe by the way this is
the message I think I gotten myself
deliver to the CEO of this platform
where they come to see us like to
deliver and and by the way in this
dimension I will always prefer soft glow
and dual governance
shared governance than of course
regulation but of course if they don't
find the way to be able the way we need
for people but we will have to regulate
and we are ready to do this as you know
in the digital service act at the end of
the year so that's basically I missed my
my goal my target I I think I think like
the number of data it's not trimming it
but six minutes are double it so sorry
for that Q&A please thank you thank you
very much I have in this process of
making the white paper on the data
strategy on there quite quite time
pressure it has been inspiring to to for
us to listen to our president from the
lion because she says that with new
technology should not come new values
that is that is so fundamental and I
think it is it is very well put because
this is this is the idea to have the
best possible tools to use them in the
best possible way but to stay loyal to
the fundamentals those that has brought
us to here
and this is not just about protecting
ourselves it is also about technological
serenity as Europeans and that is the
concept we have been discussing a lot
because it can be easily understood or
misunderstood as something that has
turned towards other people but it's
basically just about ourselves it starts
by ensuring our data infrastructure our
networks to make sure that they are
robust and resilient enough to reduce
our dependency and other parts of the
world especially of course when it comes
to crucial technologies as I previously
said my pledge is not to make Europe
more like China or more like the US my
pledges make is to make Europe more like
herself and on that basis work with the
rest of the world and I
these pockets that we have presented
today is a good step in that direction
of course this is just the very
beginning because today we launched a
12-week public consultation we invite
every strengths of society from all of
Europe to come back to us in order for
us with that inputs to assess its and
start preparing what may be needed in
legislation but hopefully also to launch
as a leader such investment and funding
that would allow us to make the most of
all the promises that technology holds
thank you thank you very much commission
and retinyl I also miss my targets
because I skipped your name at the
beginning so a moderation is perhaps the
future because it's stress traits so we
not take a few questions
we will first want to focus on the
digital package and then towards the end
we may also take questions linked to the
other items on the college's agenda so
the gentleman there was first Xavier
financial times in the digital strategy
paper you talk about platforms that may
have a special obligation to from what I
heard from people for excellence share
data and I just wonder if you could be a
bit more specific on on the gatha's
whether you would force them to share
data and how that might work as a
consideration as I understand that
as sets we have a special consideration
for dominant incumbents because the role
they play in the marketplace is a very
different one from sort of more
old-school dominant incumbents because
of the dynamics of the data economy
network effects the data how easily you
can lean in on a neighboring markets but
we have not put pen to paper as what
should be the exact obligations the
first thing is more for us to make sure
that the people who provide the data to
the platforms that they have full access
to the data that they themselves are
creating in that respect so that they
can actually use them and make full use
of them
I've an antenna pop with all street
journal' still on the platforms and
their market dominating position when
you when you say you haven't really been
a noun you do have like a quite a track
record of competition cases that might
have informed you where the problems lie
in terms of platforms using data they
pull from smaller players on the on the
platforms or all smaller rivals and then
using that data to quash competitors is
that a direction that you will be
inclined to regulate because as you've
said fines don't work thank you
well finds work in that respect that
they punish illegal behavior in the past
season desist decisions make you stop
what you're doing not to put anything
that has the same effect in place so far
so good
past is punished illegal behavior has
stops then what about the future what
what to do in order to repair the
marketplace if that marketplace for your
rivals have been de facto ruined and
here you see that with the cases that we
have so far this is work in progress in
the first Amazon case where we stepped
in very early and took commitments the
market remained opened and you still see
competitors in ebooks thriving out there
if you take the latest the Android case
we still remains to see if the
preference menu will actually work and
allow others to be chosen by consumers
but the thing here is to consider what
kind of sort of obligation do you have
no matter the specific investigation
that we may go through if we have a
suspicionless something illegal is at
stake and I said this is now on our our
workbench the most obvious one is what
has been asked of us of our precedents
and the digital Services Act what are
the responsibilities you have on
contents the second thing that we're now
also pushing is a discussion about what
are your obligations sort of without
considerations of sort of illegal
behavior but because you are a dominant
player in the digital world to sort of
to reconsider that because it's a
different creature than what it was in
an analogue world where marginal cost
was still a saying that you would have
to consider where data travels much much
slower than what they do today like to
have it I'm responsible for internal
market and I see that today you have
some
position of these platforms when you see
this part from being in a position to be
a gatekeeper and that's not what we want
for our internal market so we will have
to watch this extremely carefully in
order to have again here not to create
not natural bias that obviously we start
to see so here of course we will have
regulation ex ante and and by the way
win from these platforms please
Thank You Samuel Stoltz in your active
here I have a question about the AI
white paper if I may so in the scope of
high risk AI technologies the Commission
has identified a series of critical
sectors and critical uses however the
executive has stopped short of
identifying technology manufactured from
outside of the European Union in certain
authoritarian regimes as potentially
high-risk do you have full faith
therefore that a itec manufactured in
certain autocratic countries worldwide
is not of any risk at all to European
citizens that's a very good example but
you have to respect on high-risk the one
you the one you are throwing is of
course the fact that when you are when
you use an Android for specific
application you can use it we say high
risk when it has a strong impact on you
on your life or on the society and and
of course here we need to watch
carefully and when we say carefully it
means of course what the argon is doing
but I just remind you something in an AI
world so a great is reacting on the very
least action not determinist this is why
you need to understand also what is why
going and you need to understand the
data set because because regarding
certain data set you may have a certain
outcome versus others and this has
nothing to do with situation you
mentioned
but but it's true also but for some
specific applications you will need to
know also if it is personal data how
that being used is it legally is it
illegally to say respect our value or
not and this is a subject that we will
have to turn to to to monitor for some
specific applications very critical we
call it critical dis also measure we may
ask to make sure that this compliance
with everything to retrain well great
locally in Europe with European data we
could be ready to do this if we believe
it is appropriate for our needs and for
our security
next question yes please here thanks
Natalia drastic from Bloomberg I'm just
a question about the digital Services
Act and where you might look at the
liability for platforms do you have any
sense how you might overhaul those rules
at this point are you you know committed
to giving platforms more
responsibilities legal responsibility
for what user is post on their sites
Thanks as you may have seen we have been
extremely busy just getting so far in
actually less than a hundred days both
with with a far-reaching idea about
where to go and how to use digital tools
with AI and with scoping the the data
strategy so the digital service act that
is for later but what you see in our
mission letters is a very sort of clear
working description that there is also a
responsibility for what you actually
carry of content and how we will put
that pen to paper on those issues that
still remains to be seen but it is very
clear that we have the ambition to say
well you have a responsibility when you
are a content provider one way or
another
I've read well we do this within the
next eight months it's for sure
11 in other words of course we are
entering hearing into that with into
dialogues with these platforms and like
with a new dialogue we don't know
exactly yet what will be the outcome we
may find at the end of the day a good
Courant John strategy which will fulfill
our requirements especially for every
things that we have to take care and you
know regarding the responsibilities of
the platform and by the way this is why
personally when I when I meet with MS I
said you know I will always prefer a
shared governance
but we have been extremely clear if it
doesn't work then we will have to
regulate but again no thing is decided
like my dad said yes we are into in the
description but time is running thank
you
any more questions yes the gentleman
there
Thank You Nicholas Wallace for science
magazine
I appreciate the challenge of explaining
all this in three minutes as I have a
word limit but as vice-president
masticate just said the staff at digi
connect were only given a hundred days
by president von der Leyen to deliver
all of this so my question is why the
urgency why did this need to be turned
out so fast would 200 days have been a
problem or is there something really
pressing here that we had to address
well I think there is a sense of urgency
yes because surely I think so so
passionately showed it here Europe is
not just following there is a real
potential of taking the leads we have
strength when it comes to business to
business technology a lot of industrial
high quality data is being produced
right now to be able to put that
together to make the most of it that
gives us a sense of urgency and second a
question about how to use artificial
intelligence to make sure that you make
the most of it while managing the risks
well that's a complex thing because
there's the origin of the technology
there's the sector's use them it's how
exactly we use what data was used to
train it and here we find that well it
is important that our democracy can
deliver solutions but not without
listening and listening very well and
this was why we found they it was a
sense of urgency to get the public
consultation started so that we didn't
get an input from scientists from
businesses from NGOs from governments
all over Europe from people who take an
interest in order to see that a
democracy can make a frame to manage
risk but also enable so that we as
citizen get the most of it and I think
that sense of urgency has been the
driver through these first actually less
than 100 days that had allows us to put
this strategy in front of you and to be
very honest with you
we have to allege that we didn't start
from scratch
I was impressed of course my graduated
already here but not me and when I
joined I was impressed by the work which
has been done by the previous Commission
existing already in the Commission in
the DG's a lot of work already a lot of
of discussion with with many
stakeholders this is a very important
subject and an elite by the way any
member states most of the member states
are already for some of them issued
their own vision and I think it was time
for us by the way this is also our
mission to put everything together and
to have this current vision that
Margaret explained beautifully for a
high but also and here believe me in
industry there's an urgent need
immediately we will not be able I mean
in six months it will be already
something different so yes if we want to
announce this alliance that I described
we better do it now
we do not feel that we've been doing
this in in just by the Commission one of
the things that impressed me was that
350 businesses were ready to take on
board as a pilot the ethical principles
that were suggested by the high level
group to create trustworthy AI because
these different principles they were
translated over into a questionnaire and
this is the Commission it wasn't short
was a long one and they use that and
they figure it out well what is what
works for us how can we actually do what
we want to do by using these criteria
and be part of the process and and what
is gone into here is also the response
from you 350 participants have been
pilot testing how to work with epic
ethics when you do artificial
intelligence okay what questions perhaps
in the middle um hi Vlad back smile with
your active as well
my question is linked to to what's being
discussed before and in particular to
the the Commission's drive to foster
synergies of projects that are already
being implemented across the EU one
specific example that's been mentioned
and the paper is Gaia she Germany and so
the Commission will try to facilitate mo
use what member states by the end of
this year how does the Commission
envision the content of these mo use and
what are the concrete sort of steps
beyond 2020 if that D is happening use
are designed to facilitate that's a very
good example of the urgent situation
where where we stand in order to have a
current approach at the level of the old
EU and it's true that guy alex is a good
project by the way I spend a lot of time
myself
I knew the project before joining the
Commission and not very well the project
and I had a lot of discussion with
patate million euros a cheese is clean
behind this strategy and and we believe
that what we present and especially the
understand that we have two pillars in
the infrastructure engage all of you
either is precisely what what I
described as you need to have a specific
and secured let's say open and secure
and scalable cloud specifically for
things that we discussed today and
mainly mainly in the public environment
but not only if I want to summarize and
we believe that we have today a tool to
do this very quickly including by the
way everything or the work which has
been done with - - - to start the
strategy of Galax with what we will
present as an open platform solution
close to the HPC strategy because then
it is connected it is related you need
computing power and you need secure
platform so we are going to description
with with the guy gags funders and we
believe that will be they could join
this initiative but of course friends
for example are also another initiative
we meet them and we believe that here we
could have a Korean strategy for Europe
but then of course the second alliance
is more for the totally private world
like any other alliance and this is
where we need probably a big tube in
yours investments and we know where we
will we will find this money which is a
lot of money
I think hi always next and we are
getting close slowly close the end of
this press conference
yeah the doctrine facts item after which
very kind of hang when the smoke clears
and yes the target and in the bin Marco
Messiah Britain's young gets me a 14 big
Marvel suddenly I declare to exact
digitalis is only he be the bin marked
manner fog is hum the organs concrete
diseases project they're a
commission in the brick gnomes with some
vegetable the European service ecard
the glitters on digital is young the
greater Sundin bin mark this project is
a hope a Parliament block yet with all
estimate right again lady elección Hamza
the house gland the magnets Vedas a ago
sir
and kindig invested digitally to comfort
on things at the Commission gland was
Austin loop lead of this internet 420 on
Givaudan is isn't yet slaughter by
getting fake news miss powertrain we are
physique at once does was he gets looser
in the to comfort man that once doesn't
seen on sponsor yarn it without only one
free concussion
we miss you on that faulty pass a
receptor a particular cebu with the
modest origami sec past year for the
journey
Sakhi be the most concern Lynette you of
the sriracha Internet as could you be
seated Jonathan piloted from the Liberty
from antiemetic and cashews okay sure
a Deku Palace is usually the part with
you is a delineator mama
so what class should caught on a tooth
up fetus lot hello Matt not related by
example select the blue key strikes
efficacy calcio show's over ah g'day may
majority says he Padre will be the
linear activity mr. Joe bleep Oscar I
want a trek nvidia metronome I love at
all at all Sudoku Mississippi to
converse in welcome Abu advocacy demo
super block a delicacy question Matt no
sure sure you know generally Salah
continent on an idea Polly
yeah met not directly dubious nakshatra
sexually convolution effect news leader
parity or his two sisters Allah so too
shall be pipette melodically he presses
Ahmad Ahmad
that were minuto regular shopper a lipid
from the test fit of a leafy obviously
the vessel met no way continent it
exists they didn't exist Empire Cassini
it is somet no melody special applaud
from permit as a metronome admissions at
the code wholly automatic mode dolly
categories sauna category not intended
racism of Palawan control e-liquid
multiple passes mo at an actual a not
inoperable
the system Abbas intelligence official
Jana another pillow-fish
doc inaudible Lanka basilica's opal I
can sois all maitre d's obligation
straight for ye in the truth Tippecanoe
laughs and linear an abortion swass
jamie-lee pet from the purple net
developer met Bobby J the red rocker
blue companion don't need my moss it
faster just one thing to add because I
think you're completely right to say
that in 20 years time digital will look
very different
just as it looks different today than
what it did 20 years ago but what we're
saying today is that we have the
willingness to suggest that we shape
Europe's digital future and that is a
responsibility for our legislature for
the people who are elected by the voters
and and we are here to pave the way for
that to happen and I think this is the
European model over the decades in our
democracies we have been willing to say
these things actually we don't want that
take agriculture some of the most
damaging pesticides they have been
banned because we didn't want to take a
chance on biodiversity or drinking water
and yet a lot of other pesticides has
been allowed with proper safeguards and
and we have done that knowing that of
course that there would be a downside to
this some may actually could have had
good use the pesticide that was banned
it's a European model to say well this
we don't want to do this go go go and
this has brought us to here it's that
it's the best place to live ever on this
planet especially if you're a woman and
that also there is a gender thing to
this as well and I think it is important
now to say we have the willingness to do
this because shaping our future that is
what democracies are for thank you soon
as questions please
luis Crofts mx2 questions for the
executive vice president firstly in the
communication you say that there'll be a
sector inquiry this year can you give us
some indications if you're thinking on
what sectors have caught your eyes at
add tech or transport or booking or
whatever secondly also in the
communication is a review of competition
law twenty twenty two twenty twenty
three so that's most of this college can
you give us some thinking give some
insight your thinking on that particular
as regards data sharing what you want is
I understand SME smaller companies fail
to share data more easily
however there's long been a trade-off
with against privacy laws and against
competition laws how that's going to
work can you give us an insight into
that thank you on the sector inquiry
we will do as asked by the precedents
find a sector where there are novel
aspects and where there is a sense of
importance as to how our economy will
develop but we have not finalized our
thinking yet I'm the second question a
lot of people come to us and say oh we
would like to cooperate but we are
afraid that you will see a cartel and
then we see welcome to us with your more
specific proposals as you watch we what
you want to do and then we will make
sure that we see no cartel same thing
here of course we would very much like
people to share data pool data reuse it
in the best possible way and to give
guidance so that it's not organized in a
way that could be a data driven cartel
and that guidance we would like to give
of course specifically and that we can
give today but we're also reviewing our
both our horizontal and our vertical
block exemption guidelines so that
people can also see their well what are
sort of the main route but if if someone
comes this afternoon we stand ready to
give specific guidance as to how to set
this out because
these are things that are happening
right now and as you suggest it takes a
little bit of time before we have had
public consultation and public
consultation and considerations and are
ready to to launch new guidelines and
this is why of course we invite people
to come as of yeah well some time ago to
ask specific guidance to be able to do
this thank you very much
I don't see any other questions well I
actually see one here please
last one
so it is Zoey didn't live from New York
newspaper what we have today as far as I
see
algorithms are trained by humans and
operate on the basis of the real words
fact which explains why many times
algorithms can produce discriminatory
results they societal bias so my
question is whether this Commission
believes the training algorithms will be
enough to mitigate the risk as the
Commission president said without first
confronting the stereotypes that
influence the trainer's of algorithms in
shape the bias because at the end of the
day the opacity of an algorithm is less
of a problem than the actual facts based
on which an algorithm operates thank you
that's exactly what we talked about
today this is all the change that we
have to that work to make sure it's
compatible with our values and you're
absolutely right it's not only all right
it is it is also
the result that we can see so we have to
make sure that everything all along the
chain will be compatible with a value
that we discussed today and and this is
why this is a quite complex exercise
that we present today and I think my god
unique unique on the planet we are the
first one to do this we will make sure
that your question will be advised to
exist hundred days consultation but
again I insist in order to avoid what
you mentioned which Queen phrase our way
of living and our values we will have to
make sure that we check everything all
along the chain I think you're perfectly
right
and the thing is that we as as humans I
think can live with the fact that we
were not successful today because we
will do our best to be successful
tomorrow in non-discrimination and doing
our best problem is when you have or
what we as individual dues summed up by
a machine then you're really confronted
with the world as it is and this is why
when it comes to skills and attracting
talent the most obvious thing is to
attract a more gender balanced set of
people to work with artificial
intelligence and to make sure that when
you use data that you know the quality
of your data because if the quality of
the data is such that they are basically
only usable for one purpose well then it
should be labeled
only usable for one purpose or otherwise
you'd have to do something specific to
counteract the bias that is in the data
so that you as a user will know there's
a number of medical tests that are made
mostly on men may not be the same if it
works on women I think even more clear
there are molecules in in
pharmaceuticals that work in one way in
one race and a different way in a
different ways so it's very important if
you do not have full data sets that you
label
well this is what this has been trained
to do so this is what it can do and if
you find that you are capable of
correcting the bias well then that you
can do that in a qualifier way of doing
it because otherwise you end up in a
situation where you do not know what is
actually happening all right she
executive vice president commissioner
many thanks oh good afternoon to
everyone
you